most people only pay attention to the
final product of a successful
entrepreneur
[Music]
they say things like I can never be like
them or they got lucky but most don't
see is what they've overcome today we're
down in Dallas Texas to meet the hugely
successful author an entrepreneur
Patrick vet David as a young boy Patrick
bet David emigrated to the United States
from war-torn Iran served in the US
Army's 101st airborne youth and soon set
off on a one-man mission to save the
insurance industry from self-destruction
a true industry disrupted
[Music]
give it away for free I feel working
likes giving it away
this is risk well that was a swing
sanitarium roughly my fifties begin to
get 24 years old my energies be nuts
more than too big oh my god I won I
would run from the bus I don't know
there's no wisdom on the left they're
all a lot of say that I you can't say
that
you seriously think their lies and we
know it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the one that is most famous is